hi this is todd maleco the seo faculty
for market motive an online marketing
consultant at stuntdouble.com and i'm
here to give you an introduction to
search engine optimization we're going
to look at some of the important seo
terminology and concepts as well as take
overall
high level view of what you'll be
learning during the search engine
optimization course
so what is search engine optimization
it's the process of affecting your
website or web page to impact the
visibility in the search engines natural
or unpaid organic search results now
what this means is if you do a search
for something like seo you'll get some
results here you can see a couple good
results and they'll tell you various
things about search engine optimization
and when you're doing this search for
something like what is seo you'll see
ads to the top and to the right
and you'll see that they're labeled and
there's a little thin background there
as well these are the paid search
results now the organic search results
are those that are not impacted or
influenced by those paid search results
they're not advertisements they're the
quote-unquote organic search results
and search engine optimization is simply
the practice of improving your website
for each of the search engines so that
they rank more effectively through
understanding of the way that the search
engines classify and rank documents we
can create a strategy for search engine
optimization and this strategy is
dictated by a lot of different areas
could be keyword research it could be
content development it could be site map
optimization the design and speed of
your website the ways and the places
that you interact in social media you're
going to need to monitor your rankings
and your analytics and improve your
website based on these things and
document all of these things
throughout this eight part course on
search engine optimization we'll look at
a variety of areas that impact your
website and web pages search engine
result positioning we're going to start
with the on-page fundamentals and the
things on an individual web page that
will impact your rankings and we'll
start by looking at a site that i
developed and worked on myself for a
small business that i run we'll look at
what we call signals or factors that we
send to the search results through our
web page optimization that shows them
that this is relevant for this
individual keyword we'll look at the
best practices for how we set up those
urls and the titles and keeping our copy
accessible and relevant to the keywords
that we're trying to rank for and we do
that through our keyword research we'll
create some seed lists and explore the
entire keyword universe within whatever
your niche or business is that your
website is about will determine how
valuable those keywords are and which
ones are most important to your business
based on what you're trying to do and
then we'll take a look at those same
keywords and do some opposition analysis
we'll run them through a search result
and determine how competitive they are
if it's something that we can actually
compete for will prioritize our
strategies and our optimization
techniques based on the understanding of
the keyword difficulty and benefit and
then we'll make organizational decisions
about our website based on this
understanding with the newfound
knowledge of our keyword research and
how it relates to our website we can
organize our navigation and our user
path priority and make sure that our
site is accessible and designed
effectively
clustering those keywords for individual
landing pages so that we can later track
those landing pages and track those
users that came in through our site
through the search engines we'll also
look at some of the domain
and site-wide best practices
considerations like exact match domain
versus partial match domain we'll look
at some duplicate content concerns and
areas where you might want to block
things with robots.txt or redirect
content with 301 redirects we'll look at
some sitemap best practices and how to
further organize your site at the
site-wide and domain-wide level so that
bots or spiders crawl and index your
site effectively we'll also consider
link building and the types of links
that we want to get and the value of
these links we'll look at some tactical
examples of how to build links as well
as some considerations and factors that
may have a negative impact on your
website's search rankings
if your local business will look at how
to register your business for local and
optimize those listings as well as build
citations in local directories and we'll
take a look at 20 of the local search
ranking factors and how each one of
those individually affects your website
and its position in the search results
finally for documentation purposes we'll
look at conducting site audits in 12
different common areas including on page
off page content crawling and many
others we'll look at common site issues
and over 50 questions you can ask to
make sure that your site is as optimal
as it can be for the search engine
through this documentation through this
understanding we'll start to form our
website goals and we know from the onset
that our goals with seo includes links
and higher rankings and improving the
traffic and ultimately conversions and
sales to see what's good for the
business what's important to the
business what keywords should be a
priority to the business ultimately that
those keywords support the business
goals and the business directions of the
website that you're working on but
before we get into goals and how it
impacts analytics and how we work with
google webmaster tools let's step back
and take a look at how search engines
work so understanding exactly how a
search engine works would require
understanding all of the algorithm
factors all of the search ranking
factors all of the bells and whistles
and black boxes that are at the
googleplex to display relevant results
to their users but in its simplest terms
there's three ways that a search engine
works and the first is the web spiders
index documents and we'll take a look at
what each of these areas means in more
depth as we go through this but the
spiders index documents and then the
users search for keywords
the algorithms then return the query
results
the algorithms decide what's relevant to
what the user searches and presents
those results to the user so as we dive
into this a little bit deeper we see
some synonymous terms associated with a
lot of this vernacular and seo jargon so
we want to identify
and define some of these terms as well
as the synonymous terms associated with
them
so with spiders they're also called
robots or crawlers it's synonymous with
spiders these are all ways to say search
engine spiders and these spiders crawl
the web thus they're called crawlers and
they're software to find and organize
websites they're just creating that
index that database of information the
spiders are the document discovery phase
they find websites and crawl to another
website or they find a site map and they
crawl to another web page and they index
those and put those into the database of
information and that database of
information is called the search engine
index you'll hear this called the index
the database google's database index etc
and the individual documents that they
index
within the database
consists of different file types it
could be a html document it could be css
it could be a adobe pdf portable
document file it could be a lot of these
other files but it's really an
individual document and they spider and
collect and organize a multitude of
documents so these search spiders index
documents that's the first step in the
process
the second step in the process is the
user search for keywords
and users are on a variety of devices
and they're searching with a variety of
intent and they expect that they're
going to get relevant search results
that's why they come back to google is
because they return relevant results
so these users are searching on a
variety of devices so you need to make
sure that your
website is mobile and pc friendly we're
entering the era of more people
searching on mobile
quote-unquote devices being ipads and
iphones and android devices than ever
before it's actually surpassing desktop
market growth and there's more people
searching
on mobile than on local now we see that
this is an important component to serve
the user what they're looking for based
on if they're mobile or on a desktop
because the experience is going to be a
little bit different
and the users search keywords they
search almost exclusively on google
google has
70 or 80 percent market share so when we
talk about seo most times we're talking
about google they serve over 5 billion
queries per day that's over 115 queries
per month and of those 5 billion queries
per day
around 15 percent
are new searches meaning something
that's never been searched for before so
these users are searching
phrases and keywords that have never
been searched before on google they're
unique
these unique key phrases help to
demonstrate the difference between long
tail and short tail keywords
in the long tail people will search for
longer phrases
and new variations and terms and phrases
that have not been searched in google
before and this demonstrates the vast
array of the types of information that
people are searching for and expecting
to find in the google search results at
the short tail of that is very short
queries that are repeated often maybe
online colleges or colleges being an
example of what we call a short tale or
head term and at the head there's very
high search volume but there's also
very high opposition in those search
results there's a lot of people who want
to rank for the term colleges or even
online colleges you start to get into
the chunky middle or fat head when you
add some phrases to that and then you
get into the long tail of the keywords
when you get into a phrase like online
nursing degree college programs in
michigan the more phrases that you add
the more information that you add to
that search query the longer that phrase
is and the more it gets into what we
call the long tail of search keywords
but what's really important here is the
user intent
with those long tail keywords it's much
more pronounced when you can see that a
user is searching for a long tail phrase
and they're looking for very specific
information there's also other types of
user intent that we can segment and
account for and create our strategy
around we can make sure that we're
serving the appropriate type of content
to someone who's doing an informational
query that starts with something like
what is or who is or how
how things work if they're doing a
navigational query they're probably just
looking for the website and typing in
www and what we're really searching for
as a search engine marketer as a seo
professional is those transactional
phrases currency trading software demo
currency trading software download these
are examples of phrases they're going to
convert into business and that's what
we're looking to do with our seo
strategies and campaigns we want to
target these high value users and a very
good predictive indicator of high value
users is cost per click or ppc prices
google is selling each one of these
keywords and we can see how much it
would cost to purchase those if we were
going to purchase those through ppc
advertising
there's a big difference between things
like currency exchange and currency
trading the intent with currency
exchange is a traveler exchanging some
money to travel with currency trading
it's a stock broker looking for macro
economic information and looking to
trade currencies with some type of
platform the difference between buy time
shares and sell time shares is about 20
or 30
the same applies to car insurance versus
car insurance quotes the level of
specificity
and intent plays a big role on the value
of search traffic and that's one of the
things we want to keep in mind when
we're doing our keyword research and
certainly that we want to keep in mind
when we're understanding how search
engines work and that users search these
keywords in different areas of intent
only about 10 percent of these are
transactional so we really need to
identify and segment these users when we
are able to do that we also want to
understand the volume the number of
people in that short tail searching for
a phrase you can see here through
adwords tool that we can see the number
of average monthly searches this is what
we refer to as search volume and we can
see the suggested bid price for that
type of keyword is in this case 88 cents
and these two
figures give us some nice data to make
decisions around our keyword research
we're looking at the value of that
phrase with the cost per click
and using that and search volume
together gives us an overall benefit
idea of what it would be like to rank
number one for a keyword and the value
associated with that
the last section after users search
keywords is algorithms return query
results this is really the nitty gritty
of how the search engines work an
algorithm is a software program to
return these search results it's going
to make decisions based on relevance
with over 200 factors at their disposal
there's lots and lots of things
powering the back end of google to make
the decisions of what gets returned in
the search results so algorithms
determine why a page ranks where it does
if i search catch atlantic sailfish
those first three sites why are they in
the positions that they are positioned
in well it's because of their page
authority their domain authority and 198
other factors and that really is the
secret sauce or the black box of search
engines is their algorithm the algorithm
that returns those search results to the
users and we can get idea of a lot of
these factors from this document here
and the moz
seo ranking factors we can see the way
that they break it down into page link
authority page level social and there's
a lot of different aspects and signals
and factors that we can look at here and
these again are synonymous terms factors
variables signals indicators these are
all search engine factors that impact
where your web page or where your
website is going to show up in the
results and the algorithm is what
determines that we don't want to be
chasing the algorithm we just want to
understand how it works if there are
mild subtle changes we can change our
site appropriately so there's a lot of
very complex functions going on at the
query and algorithm level you can see
that they're determining the topic or
doing keyword relevant scoring on the
documents that they have indexed that
they're now presenting in the search
results and they want this to be fast
when a user performs their query google
responds to that almost in real time
it's very very quick and they suggest a
lot of the keywords now with google
suggest you can see they're determining
user intent they're seeing if there's
local intent they're expanding queries
they're doing spell correction a lot of
things are going on at that query level
and then the algorithm is producing
those results based on keyword relevance
based on overall relevance and quality
of websites and it's presenting those in
what we call the search engine result
pages
you'll often hear these called serps
that can be the search engine result
pages or search engine result positions
and the positions are the individual
locations if we do a search for this we
can see number one two and three for
ernest hemingway we call this the
keyword rank the keyword ranking the
keyword results is the collection of
those serps or search engine result
pages and each of these individual
positions
is a keyword rank ranking or your
keyword result and those are determined
by that algorithm
search traffic refers to the visitors
that come to your website through the
search engines and search traffic is
traditionally more valuable than other
types of web visitors because of the
relevance and the intent of those users
so we want to determine the overall
value of a seo campaign and say why is
it important to rank for these keywords
well the real benefit is obviously in
achieving that number one ranking or
achieving a first page ranking and there
are some estimate click through
on various search results based on
studies that have been done here's some
of those numbers i don't put a lot of
credence in there training.seo book has
some good information on the value of a
front-page result and the relative
click-through rates and this type of
thing but we know that it's valuable web
real estate to be on the front page of
the search results this gives us an
overall view of some of the terminology
on how search engines work we see that
the spiders index the documents the
users search the keywords and the
algorithms return the query results
and when we do a search for what is seo
we can see the ads and the pay-per-click
at the top or on the sides we can see
the organic search results that are the
ones that are indexed by the spiders and
returned without any type of paid
placement and then we also see what we
call feature in air quote search results
or universal search or blended search
these are all terminologies for news
images and the other types of search
features that are triggered at the query
level when a user searches for something
an example of this would be the google
knowledge graph if we do a search for
ernest hemingway we see a knowledge box
here that box tells us all about ernest
hemingway and answers our question about
him without actually the need to click
through on a search result these
pay-per-click ads we can easily identify
with the term ads up there we can see
things like carousel and google maps if
there's local search intent and you'll
get a variety of these 85 search
features if you'd like to identify more
of those dr pete has a great
presentation on all of these different
features including site links related
searches similar searches image block
news results video etc there's only 15
percent of queries now that don't
contain any of these 85 search features
in a search using branded terms we'll
often find what's called site links
another feature of the 85 search
features in google and we can see with
something like macy's we have women's
clothing and men's clothing direct links
into their site for those links so
rather than just having a single listing
they have their ad their branded search
and site links to individual areas of
the site to make navigation easier for
the user the site links and the 85 other
search features are contributing to
what's called vertical creep and this
means pushing those organic search
results down the page
so there's less real estate being
covered by those organic search results
so it's becoming harder to achieve those
as well as more valuable that organic
search traffic if we look at an example
of miami fishing charters here we can
see that this is pages nearly all ads
there's ads here this is an ad this is
an ad and the whole right side is an
advertisement and then there's probably
even some advertisements in the local
map section
that's listed here below so you can see
how that vertical creep and those ads
and the different features in this case
being local are pushing those results
down the page and making it more
difficult to achieve those organic
rankings
so this is a lot to cover we looked at
all kinds of aspects of how how a search
engine works and if you need to know
more about this or any of the topics
that we covered or you're concerned
about some of the terminology i urge you
to do a search at one of these places
i've set up a couple custom searches
that you can get to todd at seo search
and todd at seo search too and these
will give you some websites that will
help to answer your questions just to
customize google search engine around
seo if you're looking for books around
the topic i suggest the art of seo
seo secrets from danny dover and search
engine optimization visual blueprint
from chris jones some of the suggested
websites are listed here matt cutts and
the shortcuts gives videos from google
on what's important google guidelines
etc and some of the other sites here
will give you very valid and wonderful
information on overall seo so we covered
what seo is what you'll learn how to
learn it how search engines work and a
lot of the common seo terminology and
vernacular that you'll be using
throughout this course
thank you very much for joining me i'm
todd mallikood